Today's One Minute Monday is: It's a marathon!
Running a business is not a sprint, it's a marathon and things... take... time to happen!
No matter how hard you work, no matter how much effort you put in at the beginning,
it still will take time and you need to let time for that momentum to build.
And too many entrepreneurs, they don't see results right away.
They think it's going to be easy. You don't see results right away and so you quit.
It's way better to spend 1 hour a day, but 1 hour every single day,
doing something to grow your business than to cram everything in to a couple of weeks,
see no results and quit and go get a job.
It's a marathon, it's not a sprint. Make sure you allow for time to build all your momentum up
and do something every day to grow your company.
Believe!
If you liked this video, give it a thumbs up.
Leave a comment below, I'll make a video response.
Thank you so much! And I'll see you soon.
Subtitles by the Amara.org community